Oh my gosh.
Hello?
I think, I think we, what happened?
I want it.
Can everyone hear my girls?
Scotland forever.
Oh my gosh.
Hi girls, Mina-san.
Hi.
Mina-san, ganky disco.
Ganky disco.
Oh, we're starting already?
Oh my God, that was so fast.
That was so fast.
Wait, what?
My body's not ready.
The lobby's going to close.
Are we all here?
We're here.
Close.
We should do introductions.
We should do introductions when we get in the room.
We can die.
We can die?
OK.
Let's die together.
I'm very anxious.
Wow.
Oh my gosh, I'm imposter.
That's not how this game works.
Oh my God.
I just thought you guys would like to know.
Let's do our introductions around this round table.
OK, OK.
Great, cool.
Wait, wait, wait.
The round table.
I'm ready.
Each girl, her spotlight should come up here.
OK, OK.
You may plus first.
OK, you may plus.
You may plus go.
I said no.
The other first.
Hi, my name's the most sister, Saki.
And I like strawberries.
Nice to meet you all.
You have a cherry on your head.
Yay.
Shut up, don't talk to me.
Oh, oh.
You could do like that something.
I guess I'm next.
Yeah.
Hello, I'm Rhea Nevermore, and I am the goat girl
of You May Plus First Generation Remedy.
Yay.
Wow.
You got that.
You're the girl.
Wait, I can't hear them.
Rain, go.
You hear them now?
Oh, shoot, sorry.
I had you guys off on my desktop.
Sorry, hold on.
I'm so dumb.
Damn.
I can't hear them.
We can smell it.
Okay, okay.
Hi me.
I can hear myself.
Who's echoing?
Turn off the damn echo.
Oh my God.
Oh my God, that's so bad.
Hold on, don't laugh.
Yeah.
Like, go.
Scuff scuff.
Oh my God.
The voices.
Scuff scuff.
You're even actually just telling me.
Just get it, just get it, just get it.
Just get it, just get it.
Can you please fix it?
Like that's just crazy.
Oh wait, that was my laugh.
Can you still hear it?
Or is it gone?
I can hear it, yeah.
No, it sounds fine, sorry.
It's good, you're fine.
Girl, how loud do you have your head set?
Me?
Yes, yes.
Sorry.
Wait, I fixed it, I fixed it, I fixed it.
I did.
Oh my God, I had it turned down.
Oh my God.
Welcome to the Via Lour and Yuma Plus Collab
where we are scuffed even through the beginning,
even though we met an hour before
and set this all up.
It was more than an hour.
It's giving poopy.
Speaking of poopy, let me go.
Alright poopy, take it away.
Take it away, take it away.
Hi me, I am Yuma Plus Special Generation Remedy.
I'm a virtual playing doctor, nice to meet you.
Yeah, nice to meet you.
Hi.
Why do I feel like I'm an alcohol synonymous?
Oh.
Here we go again.
I'm rain and I'm the problem.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
But like seriously, who are you?
Now for Via Lour.
Hey, I'm Sterani, I'm Scottish.
You can't mix my voice up with anyone in this lobby
and I will not tolerate otherwise, thank you.
Yeah, Sterani.
Yay.
Okay, I'll go.
Hello, my name is Mercy MoDeece from Via Lour,
gen one in gold.
In gold.
Yay, nice to meet you.
Woo, woo, woo, woo, woo.
That's it.
Lour, I'll go.
I'm a Lour Delay
from gen one in gold.
I'll be a lour.
Yay.
Nice to meet you, mommy.
What's up?
I'm Sheezy Cottonbum, but you can call me
anytime.
Yay.
That was lit.
Okay.
Okay, now that introductions are done.
Wait, is introductions done?
Yeah, can we kill each other now?
Yeah, get out.
Bye.
Screw you guys.
I'm off to do the freaking alien thing.
No, I'm not.
Are you upset?
Did you hear?
Oh my god, she's good.
I need to do
the garbage shoot.
Hold on.
Are you guys okay?
You know, it's yourself, man.
I need the garbage.
Do you want to go do the
cars with me?
Three, two, one,
go!
Who's dead?
Can you hear them now?
It was Amy.
Oh my gosh.
Amy's at the garbage shoot.
I literally just saw her.
I just came from communication.
And Amy is
standing over the body of rain.
Holy crap.
No, don't even fucking lie.
I'm sorry, but you're into...
You didn't. Is that the best shot?
Sorry, if that's the best you've got.
That's the best you've got.
I walked in on it.
It's literally
Amy.
It's the Sonic Heroes.
Fucking Shadow Roleplayer.
Yeah, okay.
The only guilty thing I have
to admit is that I like Shadow,
but I didn't. I didn't do this.
I promise.
Can Strony set you up?
Yeah, absolutely.
Set you up? Are you fucking having a laugh?
Amy, are you joking?
I was literally at the gas canister
watching you as you got pulled over
and then fucking sniped
rain in half.
It's like left behind.
I'm sorry, but that was a cure...
Open up my stream.
Open up my stream right now.
I'm not being gas-lipped
by a Sonic...
a freaking Shadow the Hedgehog streamer
right now.
I am not being gas-lipped
by a Sonic the Hedgehog
stand.
You're getting done.
I will say that I did see
Amy stand over the body.
Amy immediately just being like
fuck you now, that's not fair.
I didn't do this.
I'm sorry, but you seem
suspicious.
Right now, believe me, my baby girl,
I would never, I would never
have to fly.
If it's not Amy, I'm voting
for Strony next round.
Wait, why am I getting in trouble?
Obviously, it's going to say imposter.
You're so passionate.
You're actually welcome for doing half of the work.
I'll go find the other imposter while you're at it.
I'll do it. I'll try my best.
Damn, Strony, I fucking love you.
Pigeonino?
I've heard the tune, but you don't give a damn.
See you in death, baby girl.
Wait, what?
Wait, you didn't do it!
You didn't do it!
Wait, she didn't do it!
Mother.
Wait, wait, Mercy,
Mercy said she saw it.
Mercy reported.
I walked in.
I don't know about this.
What?
What? I just walked in.
I'm going to go do my shit.
If somebody kills me, it was Strony.
Wait, I'm not fucking doing it.
Mercy!
Mercy, no!
Guys, guys, I'm having a little issue.
You're cheating nasty whore.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I didn't see anything.
Hold on.
Can you guys hear me?
Yeah, can you use her?
I feel so betrayed, man.
Where are you?
My atoll.
We're so hurt by this development.
I didn't see anything.
In my defense, Amy, what kind of defense is I didn't do it?
You had no alibi.
Yeah.
The candlestick was in the lounge.
The billiard room had the freaking pool queue.
And it was like, what was that alibi?
I didn't do it.
Oh, we got a play pro punt on D mode.
Clue.
Clue reference.
That was horrible. I hated every second of that.
I love Shadow the Hedgehog.
Literally, I was like, I'm being accused
by a shadow the Hedgehog lover.
I don't know.
I mean, we can't let Sonic the Hedgehog
go down without fight.
It's not Sonic, it's Shadow!
Oh my god, please, get away!
Whatever the hell his name is, whatever the hell his name is.
They both begin with.
Oh, thank god.
Hopefully, this time, I'll actually be imposter.
I'm coming for you, Johnny.
If you're fucking coming for me, I'm coming up.
You, goodbye.
Oh, man.
I'll be a good little girl.
I'll do my test.
Okay, let's try it now.
Wait, where's the map?
Oh, where the fuck is the map?
I need to fix the wiring.
Why are they not highlighting it?
I need to do the asteroid.
Hey, Johnny.
You're pretty funny last round.
Ask the gun to move in that gaslight.
Right, we're playing gal.
Wait, why is the game sound so quiet?
Guys, I'm going to have to turn up the game sound, unfortunately.
Because that should not be making such a tiny little noise.
It's fine, it's fine.
Unlock manifolds.
A reactor, electrical, divert power to security.
Oh god, what is that?
Divert power?
Is he divert power?
Oh my god, I love the map.
The map, the map, the map.
Right, we're going to admin.
What do I report?
Oh, yes.
What the hell?
I was doing it.
It shadowed the hedgehog.
Let me talk.
Okay, found the body.
Let the rabbit speak.
So I was doing electrical.
It was coming from electrical.
Actually, I don't know where the map works.
Hold on, let me look at the map.
You can open up the map.
I walked up near and in between reactor and security.
If that were the body.
I am going to vouch for Rhea in pink.
Because she was near me all the way in navigation.
I saw her go in the opposite direction.
So I think Rhea is fine.
Yeah, yeah, he coughed at me.
So Strony, Rhea and Mercy are vouching for one another.
Shebi is claiming she saw it.
So Azura, Mamosa and Rain, you all look in Suss's book.
What do you guys have to say for yourselves?
I have to say something.
I was in...
It was not me.
Because I saw...
How do we know?
How do we know it wasn't you?
Because I was with Strony.
Then I went to security and I saw what happened.
I didn't see who killed.
Well, it was in between security.
Yeah, but I...
It was in between security and Reactor.
No, I did see Rain and Admin.
So Azura and Mamosa are now the most likely suspects.
Unless Shebi, you're playing mind game.
So Azura, Mamosa and Shebi are all Suss now.
Unless Ventilation was taken in Electrical.
Which, unfortunately, I don't know.
I don't believe a word you say, Azura.
Well, I'm innocent.
I was sitting at the table.
I was sitting at the table because I'm having audio issues.
I can balance.
Okay.
I don't know who to vote for then.
I'm gonna vote for Mamosa.
Sorry, Mamosa, but you're the most likely target at the moment.
Okay.
Wait, who was the person that said they walked to security?
I'm gonna skip because I don't know who to vote for.
It was me.
Azura and Mamosa have abstained from voting.
How fucking curious.
I'm just wondering.
What do you guys do?
What do I do to you?
Right, let's find out.
Mamosa was an imposter.
Azura is the most fucking likely.
I'm keeping an eye on her.
It's impossible.
But they're no fucking getting me in these mind games.
I know how these games work.
I'm fucking energetic.
What happens is the lights are off and they don't work.
Wait.
Whoa.
One, two, three, four.
Five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten.
Oh my god, I'm so smart.
Electrical.
More like, electricate my music.
Mommy's been so aggressive.
I think it's the lights.
Okay, look. Thank you.
Unless it's Mercy, I bet.
What?
Why?
It's not me.
She's getting nervous.
It's not working.
I think it's rain.
Yeah, it's rain.
It's not rain.
So it's both.
Right.
We do kind of need to breathe oxygen.
Not going to lie.
We need a cheeky bit of oxygen.
Very fucking curious.
It wasn't.
Wait a moment.
Who was attacking you?
It's fucking Mercy.
Oh my god, guys.
Mercy walked by me and disappeared into the nether.
I do believe it might be her.
No, I was walking too.
What was the area on the left?
I was right next to you when you
I was alone
with Rain and Rea
and Strawny.
I was with
Rain. I think it was Rain.
Yeah, it was Rain.
It's Mercy.
No, it's not.
It's freaking you.
No, it's not. I can't believe you would do such a thing to me.
Oh, is there, I'm sorry.
Oh, okay.
It would make sense
why Mercy would vote.
Oh.
Oh!
Yay!
Yeah, let's go!
Oh, fantastic.
Game play, fucking flow.
I actually like to approve it
because the pressure of being a poster is hard.
I'm sorry.
I probably could have killed.
Mercy walked right past me
and I'm surprised you didn't kill me then
because I was just talking to myself
with a weirdo.
I just wanted to.
I wanted to let you all live.
I'm sorry.
Look at me being so kind as an imposter,
letting you live.
You're not kind.
I'm not accepted.
I'm red, not blue, goddamn.
Jesus.
I'm lying. I forgive you.
I can never be mad.
All right.
Do my task and shake my hand.
Hi, I'm with garbage shooters.
Garbage shooters.
I'm sorry about last time.
Please don't kill me.
We're doing the garbage shoot boys.
Taking out the garbage.
I don't know what any of this stuff is.
I'm going to be honest.
I'm scared.
This is closed. I'm so scared.
Oh, there you go.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Why are you...
You're fine.
I'm traumatized.
Hold on a minute.
Amy is in
fucking electrical
and who does something upon?
Who are we? Ria's dead body again.
Oh, no.
She's a victim.
I literally opened the door
because the door just got closed in my face.
Me and...
I'm fucking on the outside.
And then Amy comes out
and then I go in to the back of the vent section
and Ria's sitting dead with her retort.
No, listen.
Amy,
do you have to say for yourself?
Did you tell me to kill myself?
No, what do you have to say for yourself?
Not that.
I mean, if you want to...
I can't stop you.
I was doing electricals.
Yes, you were because that's where you killed her.
She just admitted.
She was...
Strony, I think you're making money.
Strony, when you get like this...
No, because I know...
Wait, no.
When Strony came and opened the door,
I screamed because you scared me.
No, listen to...
Listen to Amy.
She literally goes.
I was in electrical.
It's like breaking her microphone.
She literally goes.
I was in electrical.
I tell you, I find the dead body of Rhea in electrical
and you go, oh, it's Strony.
I'm abstaining.
All right, then.
She goes, I'm in electrical.
I like how nobody's questioning us.
I know it's Amy.
Wait, wait.
I don't know.
If it's Amy, it also might be Mamosa
because Mamosa was cornering me
and she saw them walking together.
I was chilling with you.
No, I have not seen Azura.
Where's her body?
Probably by the table again.
Probably by the table.
She got the table.
I saw Azura talking.
It was rain.
Excuse me, what was that, Marcy?
Wait, who?
Who the fuck is for me?
Marcy.
Marcy's voting for me.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, my God.
Wait, Marcy's voting for me.
Marcy.
Marcy's voting for me.
Right, go do tasks if you want to win
or don't do tasks if you want to freaking die.
Oh, my God, Azura's we bit.
Pet over here.
Marcy's voting for me.
I'm voting for Marcy.
What for me?
Na na no.
No, Marcy's voting for me.
So when you see me floating in space
and I can't even play the game.
It's Marcy.
When it goes, oh, when
when床y is in Poster,
vote Marcy because she's gonna vote for me
last time it was Susie Baka.
No.
Wait, no, Marcy always
votes for the person that accuses her
when she's a posture
If you want to lose this crew mate have none, but I'm here at win and you guys
We know it's not she be
Right when I float away in space and it says
Ronnie was a wee crew mate everyone turned to merci and vote for her. Thank you very much. I rest my frickin case
I'm no having it
I
Because mercy will accuse someone and vote for somebody who is who is the imposter and accusing her
Back and then scrawny gets so defensive
Have a midget as a pet
Oh
I can't wait to murder
My god, why am I imposter again?
Oh my god
I like to I can hear
What's a buddy, so who wants my buddy?
I'm doing the garbage you desu
I'm gonna get absolutely ruled by Amy is gonna be gunning for me if she was an imposter
I'm glad we gonna for myself as well when my attitude is absolutely stinking in this game. I have to admit
I'm taking nothing but the pain
They legit are must be like so sick and screaming so you know what we're gonna do next then
We're gonna know and we're gonna be calm and we're gonna laugh
Okay, they're tickling each other behind over here they're tickling each other behind the bin
I
Sorry, I'm getting chased by mercy halfway across the canteen. I'm just here for a scoop of food
I'm not I'm not gonna lie. I'm just here for a wee bit of food. You just leave me alone
I actually you know what if you're imposter you should come for me first cuz I'm gonna figure out who the
Right who's dead as there came from here. So there's a dead body in here. It's a zero
Right, but there's no dead body
So we can't approve we can't actually prove
Right check in Azura did come from here. We're actually gonna be a cheeky we that and pop on cameras, right? Okay. Okay, we're motion
Right Amy and Azura together right, but my motion here. Oh, everyone's fucking cleaned up
Right Azura and Amy can get a kill on each other right now if they're feeling confident enough
They're having a wee giggle. They're having a wee laugh. Azura is holding back not really doing any tasks. I don't like what I'm seeing
We are going to do the last oh, sorry, I can count numbers one, two
Six of them eight nine ten
Okay, lovely. We're gonna go back on cameras because these imposters think they're gonna get the better of me absolutely fucking
Right, we see it Azura and Amy together again
Interesting interesting they two seem to be hugging one another
Mamosa has come out come out rails now coming my way I repeat rea is now coming my way
Not the good way rea is not coming. Oh shit. Oh, you're pissed. Oh, you can't
What I'm fucking are you going for me? Be honest. I think I think I think I think you're going a little skit
I'm actually gonna get done by real. She's so cute. She's gonna be done. I'm gonna say thank you by the end of it
She'd be
Hold on right and I'm Amy again are on their own
I kind of trust Strelny
My task someone comes I'm a little scared of she be
I'm observing my my elf eyes are open camera. Oh god. She's going down into I believe med bay
She be out of med bay
Incredibly quickly timing on she be coming out of med bay almost as if uninterested in any test meriskay is fucking over me
I'm getting nervous
Me
Only rain I found rain dead in the back of electrical nobody was nearby
But I have a feeling it might be rea and Azura because they like to sit what with each other
They like a whole pants cuz they're go
And rea together no, I saw yeah
And then I was with Azura and then she became a mocked in on us
Well, that doesn't mean they couldn't have vented from electrical to
Mercy are very
Lately I've had to do the time in order to do electrical unless Mercy vented from below
But I actually wait did I see you come on cameras from I don't think that would make any sense. I think it's Azura
I'm sorry
I'm going
We fucking cams together for half the fucking round. Are you joking? I've already done on my time
I'm about to get ruled by rayon
Yeah, cuz I've already done on my task. They don't take that long. I mean I saw my tasks, but I'm really scared
No, I don't do that. I'll stay on count. Oh, Mary's is gonna fucking wallop me
I don't trust me either. She's fucking larkin and we can talk
She was the imposter and so I was like bye
Amy's actually going to save
Mamosa is following Amy so whatever happens in that room Mamosa and Amy are confirmed to be together. Yeah, piss off
I knew it was you
I knew
I
Did you run so slowly
You know
It doesn't take five seconds to type in a code
Okay, well, I guess we'll see I'll guess we'll see
Mosa if it's if it's not her
The person that's trying to kill you
Maybe you guys are both
Posters, I don't trust either one of you now
Like a sassy vodka social beat
Only people I trust here
I'm gonna stop accusing
I'm sorry
I
Know
Walking
Why don't you know just have open we gotta give
We gotta give each other
She's our baby, I love you
I'm gonna make you sweaty more
I'm tired of sweating mommy Mamosa's coming for you
Okay, I'm here my buddy
Absolutely done diddle that round
There we go this way. I thought it was curious how much mercy was sticking to me on cam
Okay, okay, let her say her piece
Dude she be looking right man, dude, no, I think it's rain
Different it's a pitch lower
I'm skipping my boat. I'm I can't I'm upstanding. I'm upstaining
Lily walked away not knowing where I was going
Listen if the imposter wins you guys are gonna lose okay, all right, that's all I have to say
I
Know mercy mercy didn't know where she was going
That was such a quick fucking round like bro, but I didn't even have time to gather any information
We downloaded this like proximity chat thing so we can like only hear each other when we get close
Obviously it means we can like scream at each other when we're playing the game. It's just really fun
Or I think it's funny. I thought it was cute
Maybe yeah, I'm talking about proximity chat to the reeflings
Yeah, I was gonna say the hover and around I didn't really
Call it
She was she comes and does need any hand. I'm like
Did you get
No, I got killed by rain. It's raining. I'm me. Oh
My god, of course they get put together
Oh, yeah, I'm hot in you. Oh
I could haunt the haunted
Anybody else fucking died you did it
You killed the baby you did it
I definitely don't cross rain
I mean good strong. He's good
When I become impossible, I'm gonna kill you rain
I mean vocal cause it's I mean not anybody
We things we're going in the space
Is there like any secrets I like burn myself in the
I know you have a brain. Oh great
I
Still think it's freaking I mean, okay. No, it's not rain. It's you. It's you rain
It's rain
So mercy, I don't know where strong. Oh, yeah, Ronnie. I saw her like a long time ago
But mercy was in the hallway
I had walked all the way from weapons through cafeteria and then found her body there
Where Rayo, Rayo, where did you come from? I went from so I went in the circle
I went from admin to down and then through I think it's
So you were the last one to see mercy
Yeah, I was I think actually
I'm voting rain because she's a sure yes
Voting rain
Listen, I'm pretty sure it's rare
Okay, I was shooting asteroids as her you saw me sit in there and walk by sitting there
But
No, poor Rayo
I thought it was I me I think it might be
I don't think it's I I don't know anyone that I know it's I me is one of them
Yes, I freaking know I I me had every chance to kill me. We were alone so many times
I watched her do the oxygen
Maybe
Rain cannot lie. I think she's grooming you. I think it's a Zura and rain
I
I did I did see you walk past me, but you could have looked back around you might have been waiting for your moment
Because I literally ran past
A rain and no, it's not I don't think it's I think it's actually I me
I don't think it's a Zura at all. I think it's I me and rea. Oh shit
Get out of here
You cheating conniving whore
Now we just gotta get
Okay, then who's it gonna be who's gonna be
I mean, I mean
Uh, if they kill one of us
So we need
Or we can hit the table oxygen depleted
It's a Zura. It's a Zura
One of them and let them know
We just gotta kill one of them
About her off
I know it's you
Why was rain so hard voting for her old
Dude, I was trying to help her so you guys wouldn't think it was her
Rea, please don't get groomed
In my mouth
I
Real you were with a zero
God rea is actually dumb real you were with a zero
Where are your brain cells?
I'm really
These don't let me be be teamed with rain because she'll backstab me
Anyway
Is
As there's
You want to take a little breaky poo you don't need to restart I'll can chat
Hey, I have never felt so betrayed in my entire life
You're evil I mean thanks for letting me win lunch. She needed a little help
Don't lie you like it
I know you like being used you little little I'm gonna smack grass
In gold rea, I mean, I'm sorry. I mean loves being bullied and teased guys. She loves it. So, you know
Gas is abuse
Are you're sitting? Oh, I guess I guess he's not gonna be able to listen to us
I really cannot hear. Oh, well, you don't need audio to play this game. Are you're sitting? Of course not
Someone echoing
Who is echoing?
I would need it. One's game is echoing. Oh, what's my joke? What's my ta- oh, na na
I mean, you just don't like it that round though. I'm very proud of you. That was a good
Oh, no, I can't see you guys. It's pretty good
Do you remember
I'm playing mid-summer
I shouldn't do that. It's fine. What's this?
Go go
Right, I need to do cameras next so I can start freeing people
Right, I'm on cameras. What's going on? We've got rea
Hold on. There's an emergency. I'm helping with the emergency
Wait, am I being dumb?
Can I not interact with this? Wait, that's the pretend to interact with this?
Am I being dumb? Where's the oxygen freaking help help? Where's the oxygen help?
Help any oxygen breathers. Hello, how do I interact with the oxygen?
No
Guys, listen, she was standing right there. I walk into the card room or whatever then I am used dead body
And then mercy then reports. Why are we just standing?
Because I was doing I was doing the um, I was doing the downloads and I wouldn't let me go
Wait, you did a freaking nervous. She saw me. You did a task before
It's a self report. Wait, oh my god
How do you not notice the body you did a task before reporting a body on purpose. Yes or no, that's us
I think it's mercy
It's the download thing. Well, you can vote for me if you want, but it's gonna say
And then I'm gonna tell you told you so I'm voting for you. I'm sorry. Yeah
If you vote for me if you want that sounds very
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
This is off topic when the oxygen thing comes on what do you
Did I look at the wrong part of the map for the oxygen because I was trying to turn it back on
Wait, why is there a crime just on the right side of the map?
Hey, mercy, if it's not you, I'm sorry. I'm real sorry
Wait, why are you going for me?
Why should I randomly get a vote because I'm doing oxygen
Why did I get a friend of both?
I don't know why any of you ever trust stroney, I don't
I was trying to do the oxygen
No, I'm so serious. I'm so serious when I say this
I was doing I was trying to do the oxygen. I said I'm perfect
Because then I would have an alibi to say that I'm top left when the bodies were done
Right before
I will choose who the imposter is
Because I honestly didn't I was like looking at the map and it was flashing. I'm like, where's the f I'm not supposed to go
Hey, I couldn't mean
Honestly, I walked in and I was like me and rea. We're just swiping our cards having a jolly good time
Bro, I literally went one three two one
Literally and they've doubled us
You're just standing there because I literally was
Wasn't so much shock bro. I literally the horror
I didn't even have to speak that freaking round and we won literally it was oh stroney gas light in bro
I was actually trying to put the oxygen on you're welcome for a giving you oxygen to breathe
You oh did you hear me
You hear me I fixed everything
Yeah, that's what we like to see
Now my everyone can hear you now. I'm happy. Wait. Was it only me that felt that feels very target
No, it was every it was everyone. It was everyone. They couldn't hear none of you talk
What does the reactor meltdown do? Do you know what that does by any chance?
It kills all of us. Oh, okay. Uh, where do you put it on right? I'm gonna just trust someone else is dealing with it
Yeah, yeah, see I worked it off, right? Okay. Is there was this awesome about this?
Oh
Go minosa go minasori came for you to perish should I just start actually maybe I should start doing that as a crewmate
I just started to a I just started saying that I'm imposter of the crewmate
This is a hell of a right and you go navigation, which is like one of the most unsafe locations due to the oh, right?
Well, then I mean
Oh
I have to do something
Whoa
Never play. I mean he's just not allowed to play. He's not allowed to play. Um, she was killing
And she I saw me doing the reactor shit. I don't know how this thing works. I was a navigation good
I was in wiring in front of azure
She is sus though. She was laughing easily chasing me down a hallway. I ran into the open arms of mimosa
It was really fun
Rain, who were you with?
I was with mercy
Rain and marci
Where was reya? Where was reya at?
Okay, because I was also at the zero at one point. Azura, who are you accusing?
I don't remember the truth. I didn't know what I didn't accuse you. No, I have no clue what's going on
Right, right, right. Okay. Azura took a
Azura took a hot second to do any type of task. She followed me from cafeteria down to storage and imparted with
When you talk, I don't believe you
That's also true and that's very on par for you. I won't say
I didn't see anybody nearby, but the closest was ran into the lives anymore
Okay, all I know is they were by oh two
No, no, no
Oh strongy, but when I
When I actually am the poster or it's so strongy is Amy. Okay, I see how it is
Wait, who this time she's not talking that much. I literally shove up yours. I'm a little imposter. Why is
I don't I think it's mercy. I don't
She's being sassy
How about you abstain from existing my only
My only
In my only inclination is memos. Is that your cat's food dish? Yes
My only inclination is mimosa self-report is my only inclination and then mercies. Oh my god, don't tell them
Whoa, I don't know who to vote for guys. I don't know
I have stains rain abstained. Can I you will shift the eyes? Don't touch me
I don't know. I don't know. I don't know how to believe
I don't know how to believe you believe me
Because you know, you know when I when I'm not running and Raven that's when you know because when you know you
I'm gonna hang out with strongy. Yes. I'm I'm checking
We're going down on our own
You can see cameras when I look at cameras as well, can't you? Yeah. Yeah, we can both look at cameras
All right. I strongy mom. I think we're both good. Okay. I'm happy to say we're good if you're good because you're
That'd be hilarious if you killed me. Azura is literally lingering outside because she's waiting for one of us to be alone
She can kill us
I actually have to do a task bottom right to be honest
All right, I'm gonna go with me and if I die. Oh, no, don't no, no, don't come with me bottom right
I need to do. Okay. Okay. I need to do something in communication. Whoa
It doesn't matter
What oh, Azura it's Azura
Dude, I think it's Azura too. I saw her walking into electrical
Yeah, it's Azura and mercy electrical and found a body. What the fuck
What the fuck? Me and strongy are good. I was hanging out with strongy looking at cameras
Yeah, Azura was lurking around
How are you gonna say it's me? I think I'm trying to find someone to follow
Being creepy. Uh, I'm gonna vote for this mercy because you don't trust that stuff she's looking at me
Mercy, who did you see on the map? Listen to me
What?
Mercy, who were you with or who did you see at any point in the map?
I passed by mimosa
Oh, when you killed her? No, he didn't. No
It's rain. It's rain. It's rain. It's literally rain. I was
It's
Listen, I know
But why where's the reasoning Azura?
I said it. I was literally with you guys in I was literally with you guys in security
I went to the security with you guys and then I went up
I went and did my task and came back down and she said did she accuse me?
She accused me
Oh, I fucking heard that giggle at the end of his
All right. All right. She's so pretty
Fuck you. I'm hiding in the corner. Fuck this. Wait, you coming with me. I don't trust any of you guys, man
With you strongy. That's a those
I'm allowed to go. I don't know who the fuck is missing out on task, but we're literally about to get double teamed. I fucking
Run run run run run. We're getting double teamed
Oh
It's fucking mercy
It's mercy and rain. It's mercy and rain. It's mercy and rain
It's rain. Volt Marcy. They're gonna double them. They win. If they do a double kill they win. Volt rain
Well, well, well, well, well, that's it.
You guys were huddling up in that freaking room.
Volt rain. Azura, you have to listen to us. Volt rain. Listen to me. It's rain. Volt rain.
Okay, we're voting rain. We're voting rain. We're voting rain. We're voting rain.
And they didn't care. And they didn't care.
Because her and Mercy almost doubled me in Strani.
Literally.
No, we didn't man.
You guys were going to double me.
You guys were lining yourselves up to stab me in my bauhole.
Yeah, look at Ray do a fucking heal Mary on that vote against Sheebie.
We can see you on my yellow.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's Mercy, it's Mercy, it's Mercy.
Stay away, stay away from the yandere.
Hit the button, I can't call it.
Oh wait, I can't call either.
I need 10 seconds.
Oh my God, before she can get run away, run away from the circle.
Rangarenda Rosy, the pumpkin Phillipo, she's a tissue, a tissue.
Get that, get that yandere off this ship right now.
She's creeping me out.
You're not even talking, that's how guilty you are.
You're, you're, you're running in a circle, chasing me and Strani.
When I actually have the chance to actually like pay attention.
What is her up to?
What did I have?
Cause I spent the entire game fucking with other shit.
And now I get to finally play.
Yeah.
Yes.
If Azura is in the posture, I'm really going to commit.
I'm smart.
I'm not a postage.
No, she wasn't.
You can tell by the tone of her voice.
Yeah, they weren't going to double us.
Yeah.
They weren't going to double us.
Thank God, Azura, you saved us.
The gamer in six.
Thank you.
Let's say go brothers.
That was easy.
That was good.
We're going to start an MLG group of among us unironically.
Hell no.
We're fine.
Okay.
My girls hydrate.
Hydration.
This coffee counts.
Coffee counts.
Just hydrate.
Just hydrate because it's been an hour, roughly.
Thank you.
I'm sorry.
I've been bullying you a little too much this round.
Let's go navigation.
Please don't touch me.
No, I'm the navigation.
You don't play a game of fire truck?
That's an absolutely terrible joke, too.
You don't ever repeat switch tricks, do you think?
It is ill-advised.
I can repeat switch tricks.
Okay.
Nothing in the shadows.
Nothing.
Are we minors?
Well, minors.
She wasn't actually doing a task in the Slurkin Bay as well.
They're killing me again.
Yeah, we are.
Sorry to god.
I'm supposed to get the fuck away from you.
Wait.
We just...
They just treat me.
No one.
All right, it's five so there's at least a fucking witness inside.
I got it.
Using this room.
How do I use it?
No.
Oh my gosh, I got it in one go.
It's impossible, I just want to make a note, Mamosa, wait I want to make a note, Mamosa
is hard, Mamosa just, Mamosa, Mamosa, Mamosa, Mamosa, Mamosa, Mamosa, a bit of Mamosa in
my tummy cause it's fucking Mamosa, she's hardly doing tests and she's hugging the
walls, hugging the walls, what the fuck is this, oh my god, oh no, no, no, no, she's gonna
fucking, wait, hold on, no, sorry, Mamosa isn't doing tasks, holy crap, I'm sorry, Mamosa
isn't doing tasks, I'm ready to fucking hit that button, I'm not being funny, it, Mamosa
wait how the fuck did they go?
What, everyone just perfectly disappeared?
So I need to do my head like this.
Okay, we did it.
Oh, come on.
Who is laughing?
What's going on here?
Azura and Mercer together.
The real follows.
Ah, shit.
She be no follows.
Oh, come on.
Wait, no.
She killed me.
No idea.
The whole show was so close.
She was trying to get me.
Earlier, earlier.
My mother was chasing me.
I did watch, but I don't know, you broke my trust before, I mean, I don't know, I don't know what to say.
It's I mean, I was chasing around them, I was chasing her and messing with her and she killed me.
I don't know who, I don't know who it was.
She beat me up.
I'm going to say it won't stop.
She did beat me up.
Oh, you guys are so dumb.
You weren't doing any jobs, fool.
We were no dumb.
That's crazy.
I mean, I mean, I mean, I didn't mean it.
It wasn't me.
What the fuck?
She wasn't doing any jobs.
She was like jumping corners and stuff and not doing anything.
Sorry, anyone thought she looked suss to me?
I don't know what to do here.
Wait, what?
What?
Are we, I was going to say, are we can interact in each other?
Vote it out.
Oh, who got voted out?
Chibi, what is it?
I don't trust Ivy again.
I didn't.
Okay, well, we'll just vote her off.
She was so adamant.
Yes, she was.
The same tears as before.
I don't want to get my heart broken again.
We shared a kiss.
I trust you, fuck it.
I'll trust you.
No, Missy.
I mean, Blav has been a weird.
I'm in a relationship.
Yes, me too.
I'm going to abstain.
I don't know.
I'm going to do what I must.
I'm doing what I must.
I don't trust you.
What about all the time?
I'm going to kill everyone now.
Wait, Tronka's been very quiet.
I don't trust you?
It may be rare.
Okay.
We only got to be the reacting out?
Rhea go.
Rhea has been an imposter.
It has to be.
I'm waiting for someone on the other side hold react to normal all right I think
Put that on hmm I actually didn't eat
I think I just saw message that she just went from I think message is bent I think she just caught the trail under there
Sorry I'm actually sweating and try hard and I can't actually do mercy and she vented and that's how we got to that all about to win though
I need to go to cameras whoa stay on little one mommy's not looking for anything
I don't want to get vented and oh shit what happened she was dead where did you find her
I found her in what's that area Med Bay
I said I found her in Med Bay I finished my task
It's Trony it's Trony it's Trony wait why is it fucking me
It's definitely Azure because I was in wiring admin with Azure
Yeah yeah it's Trony why
Right well fucking relaxing with your accusations it's fucking mercy self report
No let me speak if you're gonna excuse me it's mercy self report I saw her
It's mercy self report it's mercy self report and I will tell you oh fuck off
Oh shit it was her
Wait don't get me mercy wait don't get me mercy it's mercy it's mercy
Thank you no one was fucking mercy
I knew I knew I saw the tail end of mercy come out of it sorry
Sorry I need to mute the girls so you guys know exactly
I saw the tail end of mercy coming out of electrical which couldn't have made any sense due to fucking geographical shit
So they're all getting fucking muted right now so I could explain that I caught mercy and that's why I asked is where did you find the body in Med Bay
She had been venting around the map but because Azure is so gun whole
Anyway I still win in that case because I knew who the bad guy was
Just let him fight it out
We've hung out the entire time
We have a cat fight
It's mercy
Okay I'm voting Azure
No it's mercy
I'm disappointed
Oh my god the clutch
I'm so disappointed
I can't believe it guys
I can't believe it
It's always the cute ones
Absolutely not
Azure we're on
Freya vented and killed me in Med Bay
He's obsessed with you
I was like oh shit
You said it was mercy
You said it was mercy though
It was mercy
But you instantly went for me when I hadn't done the single thing
It's because you said it was mercy
You're dying
It's always me
You're dying for me
So I got mucus in my throat
You're already killed me
You're getting double killed when I'm imposter you're welcome
I should go up here
To the test driven the fucking thing
Who do you think she is killing me for?
Oh it's strawnee it's strawnee
Everyone suspects it's me
I'll fucking show you what strawnee is
Everyone always suspects it's me
Alright three two one
Run
Oh it's always strawnee
Strawnee is the sus one
Strawnee is always the fucking sus fake
Blah blah blah blah
Are you fucking hearing this Amy?
Are you just blaming me for being sus when I'm freaking
Sorry I need to go one second
One second I'll come right to you in a second
Let me just do this
Literally oh it's always strawnee
Strawnee is always freaking
And it's always when I'm crew me as well
Which makes it the worst freaking part as well
Yeah because what you're saying is the truth
Turn the light
Do you guys need to do
Does someone want to do gas canister with me?
Okay
Wait I don't know where it is
It's here
What the hell they were so fast
What even happened
Dude that was fun
That was sexy
What happened
Guys you've been sexy that round
Dude strawnee was all like
Three two one grubble
And then they got me and Azura
I'm so fine
She did add you I witnessed that
She was like let's go do gas canisters together
Wait
I shoulda known
I'm a bane of a strawnee holy shit
What are you saying
Oh my god
Wait can we ban her from getting an imposter please
Wait hold on
We're missing someone
Guys we missed our lobby too fast
We gotta wait for people to join the lobby
One two one two one two one two one two one two
One two one two one two one two one two one two one two
We're missing
We're missing messy
Wait so quick
How do we
Can we exit the game now
Killers just kill
Yeah just kill
Just kill
Oh my god
Bruh
Already
Vote them off
Rea
Who is it Rea and
It was Rea and Azura
Okay sorry I thought we were all here
I'm not the imposter
It was Rea and Azura
It was Rea
Vote off the imposter
We're missing people
We gotta restart the lobby
Yeah just restart the lobby
Let's vote the baby off first
Perfect
Okay the baby first
Hi Rea
Hi
Yeet
That was my bad guys
I thought we were all here
Okay who's that
Yeah it's Sylvie
Hi
Is Mamosa dead?
Like where did Mamosa go
I'm right here
She's just quiet
I'm awake
Complaining as you wait for the finger
Over the kill button
Who's the other homie
Honest
What are you hungry for
You
Me
Yeah
I'm your sister though
Even better
Oh my god I love it
What
Love killing someone
And then gasping
What
No no she died
Oh what
Oh no
Alright who is it
Mims
Hey I cannot believe he just did the
Okay cause we gotta get Mercy back in
Okay Mims just
I don't know I don't know man
Eshibi
No I was
Mamosa
Eshibi
Oh my god
Goodbye
Is that how you pronounce it
Shibbe
Shibber
Shibblit
Shibbe
Ghost
Why is it so quiet
Yeah
I did it for us Rhea
There we go
Get Mercy in here
Alright I'm gonna go get some water
Water
We got it
I got it
Water water
Yeah
I know we can
There's like this in the lobby
Okay
Mercy them posters again
For another flawless victory
That'd be great
You guys
We are really good
For once
I fucking love when
Like there's four people
When there's two of us together
I love going three, two, one
I'm so satisfied
Being like execute the plan
You're a hit woman
Anyways my next goal
Is to follow someone just for fun
Oh just to wind them up and make them
Shibbe why do you sound so far away
Yeah it was okay I felt like Shibbe's in my brain
Oh
You're gonna marry me
I forgot
She has like an actual place to live
And doesn't live in her basement like me
I like how her kitchen is right next to her desk
That's cool
I want food right next to me all the time
Honestly Rhea was too good
I like believed her
I believed her
Rhea you're so freaking innocent
She's such a good liar
You're capable of anything
She doesn't even like change the tone of her voice
You're just so innocent
You didn't change your tone of voice at all
When lying
Oh why is my peeing dancing like that
You see that I went all the way up to 300
Mane's at 200 by default
Never trust Rhea
I can't tell
She's one of the few people I can't tell
You can tell really good mercy
You caught on to me
My mouth is dry
I'm sorry Rain
I just noticed your voice
Thank you Shibbe
My mouth is dry
I believed her to the end as well
Get ass I believed Raina to the end
I can never tell if she's a fanatic
Is she ever lying or not
I can never tell if she's lying or not
I can tell because she's real defensive
Every time you don't let someone finish
It feels like you're being defensive
And not letting the person speak
So you're deflecting
So I assume that you're the
You gotta let me
You gotta let me explain
Because you're lying
Fight fight fight
You gotta let me explain why
And then you have to tell me why I'm wrong
Honestly if you listen to what I know
I'm gonna go through it that way
Because you voted too quickly
So let me
Well yeah because you didn't let me speak
Honestly I wanted to
I wanted to
I thought scrawny was suspicious anyways
It just feels good
It's super sad
What am I gonna do?
Right, scrawny is suspicious
I see how it is
That's it, you'll get that
That's it, I'll be your member
It's funny
It's suspicious
It's a 40 days, no pain
It's what they deserve
A 40 days
What they deserve
40 days, 20 nights
You make push scrawny
You're a really good guy
You're the cold suspension
We're not gonna lie
You're really good at gaslighting
So I'll say one thing
The girls have never seen me
At any other type of motion
They're more than happy
And proud of their work
So playing among us
When I'm screaming down the make
Being like, it's fucking da
Is probably quite a surprise for them
It is
I was just like
Honestly, yeah
I expected it
Nice and refreshed, Daniel
Trouble from school
I wanna
I wanna see Azura and Rhea
Or scrawny and Rhea team up
That's what I wanna see
That'd be funny
Scrawny and Rhea
I haven't gotten imposter once
You've not been imposter?
Yeah, guys, let's give Azura a chance
Okay
Let's give Azura imposter
The statistics of Azura being imposter
Are very high now
Just to keep that in mind
Yeah
Probability statistics
Just for everyone
Don't do that
See, look, she's gaslighting
I'm gonna get killed
She says things like this
See, they're funny
This is how I get killed
They're all fine to mess with
I'm eating goldfish
A snack that smiles best
That's a regular kind of goldfish
She says scrawny
Because she says the suss is shit ever
Her names are Rhea
She's a screw
Oh no, my hair is thick
Again
I'm sick of being a crewmate
I'm gonna be
Wait, wait, wait, wait
Who said that?
Clean the leaves out of the filter
What are you looking for
There's nothing here for you
Alright, I'm talking to my cat
Nice, Ronnie
Okay, sorry
I'm like, are you doing any tests, Shuby?
Or are you just like pulling me right now?
No
Oh, take your time
I'll protect you
Go someplace
Wow
Okay, I did it
Yay
I'm a shiny safe
I did swipe card
We just did the swipe card
Yeah
Right, okay
Electrical, please
Excuse me, my lovely wife
I have to go to
Electrical too
Okay, okay, be safe in here
Safety in numbers
Wait, where's the body?
Where is the other body?
Oh my god
Oh my god, holy shit
What happened?
I was about to report
Wait, where was everyone?
Wait, where's my...
Shuby, Shuby, Shuby
Where was she found the body?
Raya was literally with me
And Strani as well
I saw Strani
I passed by those two
I was in electrical
There was a body there
Wait
Well
First of all
Wait
Excuse me
Secondly
I was shooting asteroids
And I walked down
And there was a body at oxygen
And it was Mimosa
She was probably doing like a little shoot
Is anyone being a navigation
Or to our weapons?
Yes or no?
No
Yes
I was in cafeteria
I was about to do electrical
Wait, who was cafeteria?
I know it's Strani
I just know it's Strani
Bro, you fucking...
Wait, hold on a minute
Hold on a minute
I say who's been near weapons O2 navigation
Because you have reported the body
And where O2
And you automatically go to Strani
Sorry
I know you love playing these mind games
Being like, Strani, Strani, Strani
But get to...
No, no, no, no
You're the only one
It's Strani
It's fucking she
I mean, hold on
It's Strani
No, no, no, no
Hold on, hold on, hold on
Wait, hold on
Notice how I'm nice and calm
And she's freaking out
And that's all I'm gonna say
I'm reaching on me when you
Self-reported the body
When you're the only person
Who's been witnessing weapons O2 navigation
Fucking rain
Clearly because the body was there
For a lot longer
Yeah, it could be both
The body must have been there for a while
Because no one else has been there
No one said anything
I was feeling the cafeteria
Talking to my cat
Literally all of them
And then I went and shot some asteroids
It could be Imi
Hold on, hold on, hold on
I mean, who were you with again?
I was with Reia and Strani
Was in the room with us
When we swapped the cards
Yeah, I was with Amy
In the admin room
Yeah
Did you see Reia's body?
No, I didn't
No, because she was alive
And then when she walked off
And then that's...
And then I was singing a song
Going somewhere else
Aw
And then...
I don't know
I was walking to the med bay
And the round goes fast
It's Strani
Because Strani kills fast
What do you mean?
You're not...
Right
No, she could not see
I don't even know that
Thank you
Oh my god
Don't ever fucking...
Anyways, we're...
I'm scared
Now she's shooting at us
Okay, goodbye
Imi is lost
Hi
What did I say?
She's a gas voter
Can we ban her, please?
Damn you
I thought she banned her
I'm a gas voter
Damn, I'm a gas voter
Why does it keep making me blue?
The moment she starts getting defensive and loud
She is the impostor
She's the blue nation
Sheebie, give me the benefit of the day
You're the only person in that area
Oh my god
I killed her long ago in that area
No, that's what I mean
I'm like, I had to have happened long ago
I can't believe mommy would do this
I'm sorry about that, love
I can't believe
I wasn't planning to kill you
I didn't know
Look, look
Listen, listen
Are you serious?
I wish you guys could see all the gesturing
that I'm doing right now
I knew it was you twice
I did it
Honestly, you did
I will know
She'll eat a bowl of fish
You are evil
No, I'll never be the next one
I didn't cover up
I gave you some of my chances to run away
but you kept running
I mean, a gas-riding car
When the killing goes fast
and when she gets defensive
you know what's wrong
You said that we'd double all
No, to be fair
you were the one
I'm sorry. Press the button. Thank you. Rain starts accusing her own teammates. It's rain.
Please, I want you to feel like craved blood. I'm not fighting each other. Craved blood and death.
I tend to accuse my teammates all the time. That's just her strass to kill her teammates.
I'm going to get blamed this round as well. She's hanging about over here.
Oh no, don't die. You're so hot.
I'm doing the card. I don't have anything here. I'm scared.
Are you needing pals just to get through the game? Because it's too scary.
I'm probably going to get double gold.
That's terrifying.
They keep targeting me.
It's so accusatory.
Hello, press the button to start.
Did I just close that?
And you've got all the way to freaking electrical mode.
Who the frick is talking? I can hear someone but I don't see anyone.
I'm losing out.
Did I not just hear someone?
This kid's friendly. I need my medication.
I literally am seeing no one.
It's not either of us.
I want everyone to tell me their location right now.
I was sniffing Shuby.
She was. I was doing the beds or whatever it's called.
It's not Azura. I promise you.
Open up the map and tell me where you are.
It's Mercy. I saw her run off with Rhea.
Why did you just say that right now Amy?
I just remembered because I was laughing about sniffing Shuby.
I saw her rain.
It's not me guys.
Are you kidding me?
I'm not saying it's you. I'm saying it's rain.
Let me vouch for people. It's not Azura or Shuby.
I'm vouching for people right now.
It's definitely because Shuby was following me and then I was following Azura.
Then Amy was sniffing my ass.
I was doing the leaves.
I don't want to ditch my gen.
I don't want to accuse my gen.
You're a little bit quieter than you usually are.
Johnny, why are you so quiet?
It's rain. It's rain.
Everyone has ignored my question.
Everyone identify your location on the map right now.
I'm in storage with my fellow cafeteria.
We're on our way to cafeteria.
Someone's in cafeteria.
Me and Shuby.
I was in storage with Amy.
Me, Amy.
So then Mercy and Amy then?
No.
I was literally with Shuby.
I will only say that I was not with rain the entire time.
But then Shuby was with me the other half.
The other half I was not with rain.
I don't know if it's rain or Amy.
I don't know.
I think it's Mercy.
Why?
I think it's Mercy and Amy.
Trust me.
I'm voting rain.
I don't know.
I swear to God.
It wasn't me.
I'm going to hold your hand the whole time.
I would like to also mention
Mercy did not defend herself
once during that execution.
Please keep that in mind.
It's Mercy.
It's Mercy and Amy.
I don't know.
It's freaking Mercy and Amy.
I don't know, man.
I am not.
My mic is not picking up as normal.
Maybe I was listening to it wrong.
Get to fuck you.
Get to fuck you're an electrical.
Get to fuck!
I knew it.
Anyway, I can complete my task as a ghost.
I was like, yeah, right.
You're an electrical.
I freaking doubt it.
I'm going to defend Ezra.
Trust.
You need to pop that button.
Unless it's Ezra, just doing a big switch.
I'm going to...
Oh, my God.
What is going on?
You can follow it.
Yeah.
I'm going to Mercy.
I love you a little, but I knew it was Mercy, too.
I had a feeling.
I won't continue to gas like you!
When Stronny said that Mercy was quiet, that's when I knew, I was like, oh, oh, look who's low-toed now.
I knew it was no octave.
I didn't get a chance to save you.
If I get changed to blue one more time.
I saw Mercy, Mercy was the last person.
About to kill.
Mercy, I'd like to abide my time.
I knew it was Mercy because Mercy was the last one with Rhea and I was trying to tell you guys that.
No, I know you're sipping the ass of a killer.
She was following me, following Azura.
You were following me, following Azura, makes sense now.
Because I was hoping that Mercy would read my mind and we would do a double, but it didn't happen.
Sorry, my mind play was to make my sound look more suspicious than everyone else.
I don't trust the rabbit guys, man.
Well, I don't trust the, what are you, a princess?
I'm a rain cloud, man.
This is straight up rain cloud!
What is a different rain cloud called? A cumulative member?
Oh, actually, I didn't mind that task.
That was rather cute. I found that one rather.
No, it's hot.
Okay, it's hot when I'm actually screaming and rage.
Oh, nothing does my, nothing really inverts my nipples.
Like being falsely accused of being impulsive.
I don't trust Rhea, but still.
Like, it literally, oh my god, it doesn't mean so much.
So I was actually going to do, I'm just going to trust that everyone else goes and does that.
Because I think everyone's quite altruistic in the team.
So I'm going to just focus on getting the task done like ASAP so I can get the,
and before we run out of oxygen because of my lack of judgement.
She's pretending! She's pretending to do it!
Is no one doing oxygen or whatever the task is?
I was trying to do oxygen!
How come no one's doing the freakin' challenge, you guys?
Why don't no one do the other one?
What? Are you shitting me?
What? Are you okay?
Reed, are you literate?
What are you doing?
Hello?
Are you okay?
Are you?
Dude.
Legally, being legally blind is a skill issue.
Yeah, sabotage. You're supposed to fix it.
Dude, that was good.
Not as skill as you.
I just assumed everyone else was going to do it and I can't work in to be honest.
Keep yourself safe!
I sabotaged nothing.
I thought you were pretending to do it.
Wait, we don't have our 8th! We don't have our 8th!
Are we all here?
Are we good?
Yeah, we're here now.
We got our 8th.
Oh my god.
Alright, that scared me. Sorry.
All of it here.
I don't want to be a monster anymore.
Bro, please! I want to be a monster!
Dude, I've been a monster like what five times already is crazy.
Tell me about it.
Where do you go?
Oh, Midway.
Okay, Rhea now has a plausible motive because
she corrected her course.
So, perhaps not too sassy for Latuvia.
That worked you.
You were about to vent.
Swear to god.
I have a scan.
I have a scan. Who wants to watch me do a scan?
Watch you do a scan, Rhea.
Yeah, I have.
Who wants to watch me do a scan?
You have to.
Who wants to watch the scan?
I don't want to get the power.
Anyone want to watch a scan?
Only three people.
I'm doing security then.
I don't want to be mercy.
I don't want to be any kind.
I haven't seen Mercy.
I don't know if anyone's got eyes on Mercy.
The serial killer of Viola.
Maybe she died.
I actually don't see her.
I've not seen her.
Okay, there's five of us. It's fine.
There's five of us. It's fine.
I'm scanning.
Is she scanning?
Okay.
Mercy just kills her.
She just kills her.
Rhea, wait.
Hold on.
Rhea, why did you walk right past that?
Because I was coming out of the scan.
I was coming out of the scan.
No, no, no. Rhea's fine.
I watched your scan.
I watched Mercy kill.
After we all came out of bed.
I was on the scan.
I saw Azura coming out of the scan.
I killed Strawny.
She made kills.
Why would you do that?
She just made kills.
Where did you find Rhea?
She was in Med Bake.
I watched her do a scan.
With Strawny.
And then Mercy kills.
It's not Azura. I'm just vouching for her.
I saw Azura walk in that direction.
I'm gonna ask her whatever it's called.
It's the navigation. I think she's fine.
Think...
It's Mercy.
I'm gonna be really upset because I-
Why did you report her body?
You walked right past it Mercy.
I did it.
Mercy you're terrible.
It's Mimosa and Mercy.
I don't know. I think it's you
in the body. I was I was the
one who reported it. I wasn't
there. Yeah. No, Mamosa's fine.
Mamosa's fine. I did it. I
did it. I did it. I did it.
I did it. I ran to Mamosa in
fear. Yeah, you vote for
how does it fatal mating
girly Pop that's why she's
Nothing's is going on. We
don't have to worry about a
Are you sure I mean you were
forgive you because you didn'
your collaboration.
Your collaboration to figure it out is Rhea.
Rhea is a you.
No, but I skinned.
Your pitch raised a little bit when you said that.
If I was lying, my pitch wouldn't change.
And she'd be watching me skin.
Yeah, Rhea is fine.
Rhea is cool.
I mean, Red Bay, um,
I have no idea who the other person is, I'm not skilled enough to know, but I'm glad everyone's enjoying my gameplay.
Yeah, I'm sorry to say I haven't sabotaged.
She's focused, she's locked in.
It's not me, I promise. I'm just sussing you out a little bit.
I don't know.
Hopefully.
Listen, it's one of the joes, it's Mercy Rosa, I bet.
One of the joes.
Mercy, go call and just retake me.
Mita!
It's not me!
It's just one of the joes.
Wait, is it rain?
No, it's not.
Oh my god, no, it's not.
Alright, go on.
Shibi, it's not.
Do it, do it, do it.
It's not me, it's not me.
It's Imi, she's gonna do it.
It's not!
Wait, what if you do it in the other person's report?
Fine, go do it rain, go on.
No, you do it, you do it, it's you.
I can't kill other people's stuff.
Go on then, show what you mean.
I'm gonna check on Azera and Rhea then.
Oh my god.
I've been on fuck.
Just meant to kill someone.
No, look, it's Azera or Rhea.
Look, the three of us will stick together, promise.
Where's Azera?
That's what I'm saying.
Oh, I gotta go back to Midnight, just FYI.
What?
Whispering to yourself, Azera.
Yeah, yeah.
See it?
No way.
Why were you whispering?
You sounded weird.
You said, where did she go?
Where did she go?
That's what I said.
I asked Rhea, where did she go?
Amy, are we killing?
Or did she actually go, it might be like...
No.
Oh, I don't need that.
Hi, Mims.
We're not talking?
I don't know about that.
I just don't know about that.
I don't know, I don't know.
I haven't checked Electrical in a while.
Maybe somebody died.
Maybe somebody died in Electrical.
Let me check it out.
Honestly, Momosa's pretty smart, though.
If anything, you're probably gonna die in there.
No, dude, can somebody fucking kill somebody damn?
If it's you, Azera.
It's ending.
Probably Mims, I don't know.
I'm just accusing everyone.
It's a double take, but then she realized somebody was nearby.
Hmm.
You could tell somebody this information.
Okay, I'm gonna tell you something.
In case I die.
No.
It might be Momosa, because she did a double take,
but then she saw Rhea was nearby.
Oh, my God.
It's Amy.
Yes, Amy.
Oh, my God.
Okay, well, it's not Momosa.
I just have an act for these sort of things.
What can I say?
Because she didn't accuse me even though I was seen on the TV.
Oh, no.
Rain was with me.
Yeah, I was with everyone.
Rain over to Rain to tell her that I thought it was Momosa.
It's not.
Because she's dead.
Momosa did a double take, and I thought she's gonna kill me.
I didn't see her.
I didn't see her killer though.
Listen, if it's not Amy, it's Rhea.
Trust me.
No, it's not Rhea.
I saw her do a body scan.
But she's the one that she might not have killed that round.
Sorry, Amy.
It wasn't Rain.
She accused me.
Stop killing me.
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
Wait a second.
It's not me.
Are you sure?
Listen, I can't believe it's not me.
I can't believe it's not me.
Rhea, we're the only ones we can trust.
We have to figure out
if it's Azura or Rain.
I think it's Rhea.
It's not Rhea.
What does Rain not understand about medbay scan?
What does she not understand?
It's not me.
No, but that was just the first time.
Old people should not be a lot of play among us.
Rhea, we need to
in the shoot room.
We have to be good on this.
We need to think about our steps.
Okay.
What if it's Sheebie?
Because Rhea said that Sheebie never scanned.
So I didn't have a scan.
Sheebie could be...
How are we going to know that?
Sheebie could be
marinating Rhea.
Yes, it's a smelly smell.
Okay, okay.
Rhea, I've been nothing but defend you.
I'm the most.
Each one of you.
It was with Rain.
You were at admin.
Sheebie had like five opportunities to kill me
and she never did.
Unless she's trying to gaslight.
Yes, because if we got rid of one
and my B is gaslighting you
because if Mercy was the imposter
and it's only one
imposter left.
You think me and Mercy are going to be imposter together
three times in a row?
Yeah.
Shroney was literally imposter like four times in a row.
I wouldn't believe it.
Rhea, you have to...
I have to vote as Rhea.
No, it's not me.
Who do you want to vote for?
I will vote for whoever you want to vote for.
It's over.
Alright, love, just vote me off and win.
Is that what you want? I'm not the imposter.
Okay, I'm going to vote for Rhea because
Rain always points to you even when she's not.
Oh, thank god.
Yippee!
Yeah?
I'm sorry, is there if it wasn't you, I apologize.
Yippee!
Yes!
Yes, yes!
Easy, easy.
You did it. I told you.
I'm sorry, is there a...
I should have let you win, damn.
Bouched for you.
Yeah, I had your back.
Don't forget that.
Man, is there a... I'm so sorry.
Where's my story, Rain?
You keep accusing me of doing anything.
Okay.
Listen, once you're out of the game,
I can...
I'm sorry.
I'm back. I'll just stop playing the game.
I was getting nervous because I didn't know how to defend myself.
I was running around the map, which is crazy.
I'm just teasing, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
I'm not sorry.
I'm not sorry because you were so sorry.
Where's your back from pissing?
Yeah, sorry, I...
The piss girl.
The piss.
You'll see all by yourself.
I'll find we've been imposter at least once now.
I'm gonna stop pissing.
Well, at least Azura got to be imposter.
Yeah, one time.
Well, maybe you're imposter again.
Right now.
I need the coconut prattle and that...
Oh!
Mercy DC?
Mercy? Why did Mercy leave?
I don't know. I don't know if we're gonna reset.
Hold on, I'm going in the middle.
Okay.
Hang out with you.
Should I just call a meeting?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, what?
What happened?
Mercy left, so we're just concerned.
Oh, okay.
Is her internet down?
She didn't die. We didn't know what happened with her internet.
Oh, she just got disconnected.
Oh, yeah.
Rain.
Is it rain?
It's not me. It's not, guys.
I know, but it's getting her back in.
Oh, okay.
Alright, it's...
Imposters come forward.
Oh, my God.
Wait, who is it? Rain or Reo?
It was Imi?
Yeah, Imi and Azura.
Imi and Azura?
Oh, I fucking knew Azura got it twice in a row.
Oh, you called it.
I feel bad for her.
The way that she said how she denied it, how she was like,
yeah, imagine.
I was like...
We heard that flick during your voice.
Yup, yup, yup.
Wait for me.
Ready to stand on the side of the table?
Alright, I'll press the button.
I like pressing buttons.
Press the button, girl.
Two more, and then we will...
We will call it.
Yay!
It's not really much of a conclusion other than us all accusing each other
and never talking again.
I know, it's so cute.
Wait, is Azura calling me?
Azura, what do you have to say for yourself?
Is that your mic?
Is that someone's mic or something?
That sounds like popcorn.
I was muted for a second.
Yeah, it sounds like popcorn.
Is that me?
Wait, you guys hear that? No, I hear that.
You guys hear that?
Something's crunchy.
Who's kissing?
Who's frying some chicken?
Is it me?
Someone's frying...
I don't know.
I hear static.
I'm going to turn my voice chat dial down.
I still hear it.
Okay, let me turn my dial down.
Hershey's back!
Yippee!
Definitely not me, it's not me.
Is that a game?
Pretty cool.
Wait, we can only one at a time.
I'm going to mute right now, hold on.
No, you can still hear it.
Okay, it's not me then.
Someone's talking to me, alright.
Someone in the middle, come to the edge if it's not...
If you don't...
I'm going to mute, hang on.
Wait, if you hear it all...
It's gone, it's gone.
I didn't mute.
We're getting a guy...
Who's got a Geiger counter for radiation?
I know, seriously.
Are we ready?
I'm ready.
I'm in a voucher, I want you to be a voucher.
They're gone?
Okay, thank you.
I believe in other ways.
All your problems might be me.
It's fine.
I would like for Mimosa to be a voucher.
Second last game, baby!
Make it carry.
This is the last game?
Second last game.
And then we call plain because we're the winners.
Gorge?
For a girl's 50th grade.
Sixth?
Sixth, the wiring.
The ones that are like the double ones
where you have to go to a second location
are the ones that like trip you up the most.
Like in terms of like
oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
That's sick.
Two or what is going on in here?
Absolutely nothing.
Sacrifice material.
Oh no, there's an imposter coming my way.
Sure would be a shame if you
absolutely callywacked me for one.
Where the heck is everyone?
This is like the main room.
I don't like this one but I've got a med beta.
Inspect sample.
Lovely.
Whoa!
Hold on, let me put my sample on first.
Let me put my sample on first and then I'll
then I'll do it.
Okay, report.
Hey Mercy!
Self report, self report.
Okay, it's not Shebi or Rea.
Mercy's dead on the med base scanning pad.
Oh.
I wasn't near med bay, I was all around the perimeter.
I saw me doing the leaves.
Rain and I.
And I was on cams.
Who was on cams?
Wait, sorry.
Hold on, hold on.
Who just said scrawny, scrawny, scrawny three times?
Say it one more time for me.
Is it Azura's mic?
Yeah, it's Azura, yeah.
Who said scrawny three times in a row?
Do it again.
I dare you.
Strawny, scrawny, scrawny, scrawny, scrawny,
scrawny, scrawny, scrawny, scrawny.
Self report, self report, self report.
It's a self report!
You are fired!
Let her here!
Let her, let Ramosa talk.
Ramosa, where were you?
It's a self report.
Rain and Rea were together.
Shebi, Rain, Rea were together.
I don't know who to pick.
I don't know if it's scrawny or Ramosa.
It's scrawny and Azura.
I will make you sweat later tonight.
We'll talk about it later.
I think it's scrawny and Ramosa.
Oh no!
I will let you sweat later tonight.
I don't have anything to say.
Goodbye.
I'm done, baby.
You didn't hear that too?
Is it me?
No, my turn.
The person who reported the dead body.
Yeah, Ramosa.
Bye.
Open your mouth!
Your coochie smells like trash!
Oh shit!
It's scrawny!
It's not me! She fucking voted me!
So I thought she was sus.
Dude!
It's literally not me. She fucking voted me.
Shebi then. Fuck you.
What the fuck? Why would she so aggrieved?
Wait, no. I'm not being funny.
Everyone's actually ganging up on me.
Because they can't even believe for a second
that I might be a wee bit nice in this game.
Like, so they just instantly get...
Oh, it's a self-report. It's a self-report.
Oh, go get to fuck, man.
Go get to fuck, man.
It's a self-report.
I'm sorry. I couldn't...
I just kept hearing...
I just kept hearing Mercy's ghost.
I know, I heard it, too.
it too because I knew if I voted I feel like I would have tied it
you did the same thing to me
listen to people I was about to like say food I was like
it's not about story being nice or not it's about me being dangerous which has
been proven in previous rounds so now none of you you scare me yeah it's true
and every time every time we start you always say that it's probably always
gonna be someone or you say that we're gonna be someone or you say that we're
I don't even know if they're gonna believe that I'm just I'm gonna fuck up the game
they're gonna blame me for everything whenever I'm crewmate I'm just gonna fuck
up the last game and they're gonna have to play low-main games with me and I'm
gonna claim that I am a naughty naughty boy okay this is just my task I did it
up to them to fucking figure out excuse me every round well no it's not I was
actually just with Johnny you're talking to the wall talking to your chat and
it was quite cute so I was just standing at you so wasn't you I was with
mims and
Is that the two of you?
I mean, it's not me, I was trying to find my toss.
Yeah, it's right, I believe.
It's right.
As soon as it's her, as soon as she blames me, I know it's right.
I know it's right.
Dude.
She always blames me and I haven't done anything.
Dude, what the three?
No.
Hold on, hold on.
Her accent.
Yes!
Wait, what's the dealio?
So Mamosa found the body wear.
We found side of reactor.
It was two of them.
Side of reactor.
I was with menzen.
Rea and Mamosa.
Rean, sorry.
I was bouncing for menzen.
Wait, I was bouncing for menzen.
I don't know why she's slipping.
I'm not bouncing for rain.
I'm not bouncing for rain because I didn't see.
I don't know.
I was just swiping a card.
Yeah, to be honest.
And I told you guys to go worry about that.
Is it Rean and Mamosa?
Whatever, man.
Was it Pinkerton?
Yeah, it's me.
Vote me.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it's Rean's being too quiet.
Rean's being too quiet.
Thanks for voting me.
You're welcome.
It was very kind of you to think about me.
The other one is obviously Strani.
What did I tell you?
Strani killed me.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, I think Strani.
Open your mouth.
I'm Strani.
I have to do a bad bay.
I have to do a scan, Strani.
Are you doing scan?
Go watch.
I'm doing fucking 60 seconds.
Countdown, spot the difference.
Oh my God, look at that.
Oh my God.
Oh my God, you're like, you're doing your thing.
Huh?
Well.
Well, it's not us anyway.
Oh yeah, it's not me and Strani.
We're busy there.
What's going on, guys?
You already know my card swipe.
Mama's on my fifth try.
Come on.
No, that's true.
Because before Rea, was it Rea or Shibi was trying to...
Well, it's between Amy and Momosa.
I already did my card swipe.
It's between Amy and Momosa.
Yeah, because me and Strani were hanging out in Med Bay.
I believe Rea's claim on the fifth card swipe.
Momosa, what are you...
Yeah, Rea is...
Momosa, say your piece.
No.
Goodbye.
See you later, ma'ams.
I don't...
I know who it is.
You will rue this day.
I don't...
Oh, I don't know who to vote for.
I'm with Strani.
Okay, yeah.
I was with Strani in Med Bay.
It's Momosa then, because literally Shibi and Shibi have been touching each other all game.
Goodbye.
Yeah, we were touching Rea in Med Bay.
She was doing a full body scan of my delicious bod.
Not Momosa.
What?
Momosa!
Why would you ban them like me then?
Wait, when I was...
Momosa!
Wait, when I was with Momosa, she could have killed me at any time.
And it could have been like...
Well, now we can't hit them.
Rea, because she just stood still and activated the fucking thing.
Aw.
Yes!
You scared me!
Okay.
Wait, what?
I'm so confused.
Wait, can you activate sabotage's whilst on the move?
Can you activate sabotage's while moving?
I don't know.
I honestly don't know.
If you can activate sabotage's while moving.
I feel like...
Can you activate sabotage's while moving?
That sabotage came on while Rea wasn't moving.
Aw, are you serious?
What the fuck?
Wait, wait.
No!
I was only about to hit the button!
Is it aim?
Wait, what?
I'm gonna hide and trigger the button if you want to do the lights.
Please do the lights.
They killed a mother with a baby.
Did somebody leave?
I actually pulled a clutch that's actually crazy.
I'm so proud of her, oh my god.
Wait, what happened?
Wait, what happened to everyone?
You guys don't clear the sabotage.
No one ever clears the sabotage.
Oh, it's the lights!
It's the lights, so if you don't fix it...
Dude, no, not the lights.
The lights doesn't...
Yeah, I said that we won.
It said crew won.
Okay.
Crew won?
Oh, crewmates won?
Yeah.
Oh, I thought we won.
Oh, did you finish out your tasks?
Nice.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Are we satisfied?
I don't know, man.
I'm satisfied.
I'm happy.
I want one more!
I'm not satisfied!
I'm down, man.
One more!
We need a good finish!
I don't know what to expect.
Alright, Rhea, Rhea!
Rhea, clutch that round, because Mim's members...
Dude, Mims, I was trying to include you in the imposter ring.
There he is!
I'm so proud of you.
You sacked me to cover you.
Thank you.
To go back in my...
My vaude.
I'm so proud of her.
I didn't even clear the tasks,
so I just looked at the bar.
I was so close to...
the other imposter was it was the other imposter it was rain oh it was rain okay she pulled a
stretch she pulled a classic remedy
gonna be honest actually kind of wish i was imposter uh yeah it's a little tip but you know
how to say like one more for luck uh in the behind the scenes are like lord of the rings in the
whenever he like does the scene like it obviously is the director and the actors
you need multiple renditions of the scene to be recorded out um and one and he always goes one
more for luck one more for luck which is him asking the actor to give one more scene even though
oh my god oh my god mercy killed mercy killed rain i saw mercy killed rain mercy killed rain
right in front of me no no it was it was it was azura oh someone got disconnected and that's why
the game ended that's why oh one of the hair and electric so it was not we have an alibi so it was
not the three of us it was azura i saw her killer i saw her killer we were together we were in
medbay because we were walking together in medbay you're both together in medbay and i walked into
medbay and she was dead and then we walked to her in medbay you both were together we both are you
strong you're so quiet i've no god i'm we both saw you point fingers at each other no i miss it
i swear strong he's quiet for no who said strong listen to me listen to me listen listen to me
all right so we were talking we were hanging outside of medbay right me and ame was looking
outside of medbay we were looking outside of medbay yeah mercy and mercy and rain was in
medbay together and ame went off and then i went down and rain was dead okay you want me to tell
my story i walked into medbay i did the little thing it said i was purple three i was purple three
and i told rain to guard me because i didn't trust rain and then i walk outside i lost rain
for a second i walk out and i see azura kill rain i saw the body why you've been so good at gas
lighting this entire time i'm not good at gas lighting okay i'll just fucking say it i just
tell me it's i've had so many elves i've had so many elves this entire time i actually i never
it's azura but i'm gonna skip you're gonna it's just gonna aim for me next trust me
i i saw azura but i didn't want to be one see anyone else so i'm just gonna oh my gosh is it
i mean azura i think it's marriage your voice telling her story i think it's a bit shaky
she was because i am yeah i'm streaming for well go ahead you can kill me watch me watch watch
let's see just know if you're not an imposter i didn't kill you watch this it's azura
oh no i had a feeling i told you my gut doesn't lie it's all right all right all right
most of us did quiet amy hardly said a peep and real's just being her cute quiet self all the time
it's so fucking hard it's hard when they don't give like clear info or that so azura said it was
what wait azura claimed she watched mersey kill her which is obviously never lie so it's so it's
azura azura claimed she saw mersey kill that person well let's kill that man but we now know
that's a lie so it is azura you don't think it's azura wait but didn't she not claim she killed her
did azura claim that she saw mersey kill her i was stepped through the heart i should have voted
for it but even if i voted for azura it would have been a tie i had a feeling that was super fun
that was good that was a good ending i'm now satisfied i'm now satisfied she's happy everybody
she's satisfied i'm satisfied now she's so happy thank you all for having us as a secret guy
she's so funny oh my god we should do it again in the future we're all right we gotta play
gargoyle phone with you guys you guys trust me or no hi we do
i will this is this has been a stain on my memory but strani is dangerous in game
strani is a dangerous crewmate so compliment she knows too much and she also likes very sweet
i'm proud of rea i'm proud of rea rea's voice never falters when she's also cutely evil
it's so good she gets away with so much
i'm so proud of you i think you got disconnected no that's what happened yeah i got disconnected
as soon as i was about to win okay i'm gonna give it to you so uh indulge garly thank you for
doing this collab with us we really appreciate it thank you for having us thank you for the
indulge in your remedy uh we can remedy and and indulge oh yes draw it draw it right now
draw it like the logos together oh right okay i was like uh what are we commissioning exactly
right thank you so so much i am going to leave the lobby and i'm gonna say a little goodbye to
my chat and thank you for having us thank you so much bye my close off the game the news and jump
into that bush chat we're the heck thank you very thank you so much
okay i got i got both of them unfortunately my game on screen chat freaking died
i don't know why but hey we tried bro that was so fucking fun i don't think any of them expected me
to be like that they so um a bit of a behind the scenes was um the first game we ended up playing
at viola just to like get the girls used to each other was um among us and i was so tame and calm
um oh but i'm fucking good at gas
evil women god you destroyed them i really like listening see what people say um to see if i can
catch them didn't realize i've much of a mastermind i could be yeah baro thank you for the five
me right there ryan colon underscore love love your strongy colon underscore love colon underscore
love colon underscore love um literally that was like so fun and crazy sorry about chat not working
on screen i think i broke it because i just had a membership stream um you cyberbillie the you
you mean the girls so much in the beginning poor i me literally she got freaking wrecked and decked
by me closed the door in her face killed her gen mate and went oh my god what have you done
bro that was awful i feel so bad for doing that but hopefully it was fun and not like
oh my god i hate this um yeah other than the audio issues someone said that a zura for some
reason couldn't hear me even though i'm loud in scots like um me got a awful thought honestly i
me any time it's not any i i me like that uh got hit with a scots rage i don't think you guys
know i was capable of that but i warned you i warned you and and everyone climbing for one more game
means you can be confident that they had a lot of fun good i'm glad that was so fun and it was like
i actually felt a bit nervous like starting up but i feel so comfortable with the yumi plus girls
like they just i don't know all of us seem to be on the same page like we were all in a group
called one hour before figuring it out and like i started doing like a veal or meeting like kind
of recapping on some stuff and i'm like oh you guys couldn't listen in as well like it's just a
few notes so i was like oh everyone's reached 5000 subscribers so we've got an artwork to celebrate
post and all that um it was hilarious yeah i'm ready for uh the after game stress relief honestly
scrawny rage was that rage in that badly i kind of remember i think my rage is basically me going
uh so the other person stops talking so i can say my piece i think that's what my rage is hopefully
it's not too bad uh might have been taking the piss a little bit the whole stream was great yeah
you like that i'm so glad the only you only rage on someone accuses you and you're innocent
oh it annoys me like it was funny don't get me wrong it was so funny but as soon as they go it's
scrawny and i'm like i literally have not done a single thing like i haven't spoken i haven't
claimed anything oh it's scrawny i'm like okay just because the scottish person is like get at the
game like come on i do i have to admit my favorite thing was the double kills um when like there was
four of us but two of them posture going three two one oh it was so satisfying and one oh one
and one of the kills rea was so slow to respond she probably could have reported the body in time
um but she was so slow that she got yoinked um oh honestly on the mention of five came
Paul of scrawny is getting forceful because you aren't eating your tomato
uh scrawny you're too good at the game it's actually i'm aware there's another map um i'm not
really familiar with it at all um and i have spelt modus terribly wrong in the second description
of that um the serotonin from the double kills oh my god it was so sat satisfying especially
with the close proximity just like oh hi and then like i just go three two one and they're both gone
oh and we just like split in different ways oh and that one game i can't me and mary say
didn't even get the round to voting because we had killed so perfectly at different sides of the map
oh he's so good literally can you handle it oh it's so can you handle it
this is so unbelievably good i'm gonna see if there's someone we can read i write it
oh would you look at that the whole yumi plus is on
um right who am i going to harass
there's rhea it's rhea going back online today hold on
rhea's going back online i'll help you rhea nevermore um scrawny i need you to use that
read read joe on me and say uh a um nope that's
essentially not from today let's see who's online um yes i'm going to go uh try and sleep
actually so i can flip my sleep successfully uh the bluetooth device has uh connected to
me um alias uh anuno is currently celebrating uh a wee party for her 50 000 subscribers so
i'm gonna have to be redirected to her a very hard working very oh secret thank you for the
five gifts i appreciate that um congrats on those who caught it with your face and enjoy the most
that come with it i feel so bad yes i will i'll do a recap and make sure that the girls are fine
and i haven't like uh abused them beyond their means um because we do be a little gaslighty
i'm gonna go i'm gonna go into bed i'm gonna open up my phone and i'm gonna click on the
stream and i'm gonna rewatch it because um i can never remember what i do on stream unless i go
and watch it type thing as for tomorrow's plans my lovely little rieflings is an r
um we are playing mech assault and we're also doing membership asmar which is fantastic
i gotta give good m- you caught it among us actually needs aftercare for real
alias is going to die today she's doing all the exercise for our doughnuts on that's amazing
um uh yes you're gonna be redirected into alias please be uh nice lovely alias um i'm not sure
uh obviously her temperament how comfortable she is how this how that and please do support
her as bet you just be as respectful as best you can okay thank you oh so much i will see
you tomorrow uh for some mech assault and then and we're just straight back into the fray to be
on her okay right bye bye rieflings i've been following i'm hoping but i'm hoping i didn't scare
any of you too much with my little um raging if you will but thank you so so much and i thought
you were okay bye bye well i'll see you later tomorrow as tomorrow i see you okay right bye
have a good day